that's the intro
[Music]
Oh what is going on YouTube now recently
a subscriber - I'll be my mom or dad for
like two years but sometimes I feel like
he does a dick but sometimes I feel like
me and maybe I'm shipping and other
[ __ ] Emmett repair I don't know what
the [ __ ] that accent was never in my
life I had a lot of homegirls and a lot
of my friends went through this exact
situation themselves man you see from an
outside observer I hadn't noticed
something a lot of times you guys
realize that your boyfriend's are
[ __ ] but for some reason you think
you can change him how many of us a [ __ ]
like he's selling me understood I'm
seeing a different side of him murders
not that bad [ __ ] what's wrong with you
listen if you want to know if your
boyfriend's a dick there's a few signs
to look for
so y'all might know what it is LG up
maybe let's get it let's go you gotta
know he's an [ __ ] if he casually
calls you a [ __ ] no I'm not talking
about your personal relationship and how
you guys joke around and [ __ ] and I'm
also not talking about when you get into
a huge fight and sometimes words like
help cuz girls you already know you got
the upper hand in that situation because
sometimes y'all take [ __ ] way too far
bench
oh hey drew you ain't me whatever cross
I didn't graduate broke-ass cooking big
ass [ __ ]
it's like that if the manager with
casually called you a [ __ ] like it's
your name maybe he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you got a name and that that dumb ass is
too stupid to call you mine his ass
needs to go and nobody it is not a thug
thing that is a disrespectful
[ __ ] thing so stop saying [ __ ]
like enemy dad it's my nickname he
called me [ __ ] I call him blue whatever
and sugar plum you need to stop dating
people who can't read the first thing
you need to do before you date a man is
have him recite the alphabet and see how
far have [ __ ] gets baby just
wants to say alphabet oh hey big CD one
two three eight I take K 17 it freed up
oh no here's another thing if you have
to ask him permission before you go to
places in case he gets angry yeah he a
[ __ ] [ __ ] listen you don't need
permission to do [ __ ] I believe in
letting
partner know where you're going and
discussing it just in case they get
worried but if you can't go out to eat a
simple meal with the friend because he
says no drop the [ __ ]
anything you know why guys do that is
because they're weak you see they are
battling with their insecurities about
themselves and your relationship so they
feel that they have to control you and
no ladies there are different ways to go
about it so it's not because he's
worried about you
it's a selfish thing because worried
about you is baby we're gonna eat ya
just with a couple of friends all right
sweetie we'll call me when you get back
okay love you your boyfriend right now
is honey I'm gonna go eat with some
friends is that okay that's cool with
you a big deck listen for some reason a
lot of you girls out there had this
weird skewed concept of what makes a
good guy you see you cannot judge that
moment of sanity and sweetness that he
shows you every now and then to judge
his character as a whole I have friends
who are hardened criminals and they have
good size them but their bad sides are
pretty [ __ ] bad
Jerome oh you're good to levy these kids
a word why go to jail then
oh he burned like 30 people but he pees
kid you know you dumb [ __ ] Oh what is
going on YouTube yes honey my hair
behind this head is almost there but
look at this beautiful Locks of Love
yes but I'm almost at my weight goal I
got probably another couple weeks to go
funny fat fit will resume when I get the
gold bet because I'm working on a couple
of stuff so I can share with you later
on but of course you will still get
another upload maybe perhaps I don't
know being exciting I don't know you
know maybe I'll put a funny fact bit up
I don't know I just don't feel like I
should until I actually reach my goal
but as of course you guys know you will
see me next Sunday
of course posting up a video I will
catch all then don't be afraid to let me
know what type of lock topics you would
like to hear from me yes yes yes you are
important so we'll see you all next time
talk to you later
lactate up you see this quick switch
wait wait I see a bit of a chain of
problems you a bit of a chain of a
problem they may be due [ __ ] I hate you
ooh pick up if the man that you wish is
the man to manager wish if the man that
you're with cut quasi box I can come
right but if you can't go out to me but
if you eat wait if you can well do we
here's the thing do you know why good
mmm
and your relationship so they filled in
my but then [ __ ] I H wanna keep on the
gun